une certitude c'est que ce sera la
surprise je l' ai déjà dit écrit il ya
déjà plusieurs semaines et plusieurs
jours et que quel que soit celui qui
sera contre lui au deuxième tour soit
nicolas sarkozy soit alain juppé yb
altra l'un ou l'autre voilà il sera donc
vainqueur voilà et je pense que dimanche
il sera qualifié pour le deuxième tour
parce que deuxième tour enfin pour le
premier tour les français devront faire
un choix qui d'abord un choix de
conviction
voilà et c'est ce qu'il faut leur dire
rien n'est fait rien n'est joué
les français sont un peuple libre eh
bien ils doivent prendre cette liberté
et voter pour le candidat de leur choix
avec de vraies réformes pour redresser
la france où vous n'avez jamais douté de
votre champion m'a écouté j'ai du nord
il a toujours été vraiment la cata
catégorique sur le thème je serai au
second tour mais vous est-ce que vous
avez des moments de doute est ce qu il a
pu vous réconforter
il a toujours été déterminé franchement
il m'a étonné parce que vous avez quand
les sondages le plaçaient très très bas
vous 4e quatrième homme d'ailleurs il
n'a jamais douté
je pense qu'il a travaillé et on le voit
bien dans un débat le fait de travailler
ça permet de surclasser finalement les
concurrents ça permet d'avoir une
aisance et ça permet finalement d'avoir
pour les français les meilleures
garanties pour que la france puisse se
relever enfin